okay baby
y'all ready for this
let's go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
riffin with griffin
got another one and another one
[Music]
not a lot going on this week but i saw
some craziness
the met gala i don't even know what that
[ __ ] is for
so i was like yeah you know what let's
talk about that
i saw the magic documentary
i haven't finished it but it's pretty
interesting fascinating want to talk
about that
and one of the favorite segments of the
podcast
real world advice from a grown ass man
so welcome back
[Music]
all right
anyways what's up y'all
whoo
how you guys doing um first off let's
start off with some business thank you
for
subscribing make sure you subscribe
you know
and i'm also on twitch you can check me
out on twitch
daily
uh most days twitch and once again thank
you for subscribing and sharing and
doing all that great stuff all right and
a sponsor of the show today's episode is
brought to you by helix sleep so big
shout out to helix sleep take their two
minute sleep quiz and they'll match you
to the mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life find your
perfect mattress at
helixsleep.com
griffin
all right y'all what's up uh how you
doing um back
we back at it
back in uh
griffith studios uh making [ __ ] happen
um let's see
what's going on man it's starting to
heat up man it's like certain number of
days till the wedding
um so i you know we had to like you know
get confirmations and it's like
it was supposed to be only 75 people now
it's like almost 100 which is crazy my
friends are showing up which is really
you know fantastic i'm from l.a so a lot
of people i know are here you know it's
just hard to determine like who you want
to invite to the wedding too i mean
there's a lot of people out there comic
friends and just people i've known even
even like
extended family who i didn't even invite
not because i didn't want them there
it's just like it is what it is you know
what i mean i don't know if anybody else
out there is planning weddings and and
and um
you know you know you you want people to
come you know who me but it's like you
know i can't invite it's like it's like
with my comic friends too like every
time i go to the comedy club i'll see a
new comic and i'll be like oh man i
should have invited you but it's like
you know whatever
now i get it
i actually get it i've i've actually
talked about this before in the past how
like oh a person i thought that was my
friend
didn't invite me to his wedding and now
i understand
you know what i mean so apologies to
those people who i like put out into the
ether like hey how come i guess we're
not friends that's i realize now that
that's not what it is it's just you have
a certain number and if you don't you
know what i mean and it's like we're not
like filthy rich so it's like her
parents are paying for it and it's like
it's on a weird day and it's like you
know what i'm excited about it i wish i
could show you this video rachel came in
here like we have to practice our kiss
and she wants to do two kisses and then
we have these like
you know rachel's jewish so there's like
we want she wants to do in her family
i'm sure her grandma and her mom want
her to do like a few of the jewish
traditions
like breaking the glass or like whatever
i don't even know all of them um
obviously i'm not jewish but you know i
don't care you know tradition is
tradition it's you know the a wedding is
a thing uh some people dream about their
whole life you know especially some
women you know what i mean i'm sure
there's guys out there too that dream
about their wedding but you know so it's
like it is what it is so
um i don't know
you know what i mean so here i am trying
to figure out like all this stuff so
it's like this all these last minute
planning i don't even have a suit yet we
still got to go do the cake
even though we have it scheduled we got
to go do cake tasting and make sure just
the cake that she wants
uh i don't even have a ring like i don't
i have to get like i don't even know
what kind of ring i want to get i almost
want to get a rubber ring because i'm
not used to wearing any kind of jewelry
so that is like going to be like weird
you know so i have to figure out that
um you
know it is what it is i mean i wish i
wish it was like it works like i wish it
worked like a television show where i
didn't have to do any planning
i just memorized my lines and i show up
you know what i mean that would be great
but you know with a wedding you have to
you know you're doing all the planning
and then all these little logistics too
like where are you gonna like where are
you staying like i don't want to see her
before so do we like stay at separate
hotels until the wedding night or like i
just
it's so much i could see how it could
drive people crazy and so like it then
it becomes like are you doing the
wedding for you and your spouse or are
you doing the wedding for the people
that are coming and the family it's like
so bizarre and then everybody's coming
from out of town like most of her
family's coming from out of town
and then all my friends live in town and
then it's like and then it's like her
and i are fighting over like well who
can bring a significant other and who
can't uh and all that stuff and thanks
for the super chats y'all
um
you know and then it's like we're not
having like a traditional
um
we're not asking we're not having like a
traditional like ceremony where it's
like i have a bunch of groomsmen and she
has a bunch of bridesmaids we actually
have a real simple i have one person she
got one person
you know so whatever it's our wedding we
could do whatever actually we could do
whatever the hell we want why you even
have to follow these crazy traditions in
the first place it's like beyond me but
i don't know so i'm you know you guys
out there in chat if you had
if you had like any kind of
unconventional thing at your wedding or
what kind of things that you do at your
wedding that say you wouldn't normally
see at a wedding i'd love to see that in
the comments that would be interesting
to uh see what people have to say but
like i say i'm still very i'm actually
really excited about it i guess i'm more
excited too just to get it over with so
we could just live the life that we're
already living you know what i mean but
i guess i guess like when you sign the
papers and you know uh
and you do all the things that you have
to do to make it official i guess
there's some anxiety and some like
things about that but you know
i i i've i've dealt with
whatever in my life so it's like let's
let's get it done you know what i mean
so we can like get get on get busy
living right
so
and then like you know people ask him oh
and thank you uh jagdeep uh and by the
way this is live
thanks for the super chat
uh thanks you know am i making a speech
oh yeah probably you know
my vows to her and then i'll obviously
make a speech to everybody who came and
that that's you know all the nice people
that are there so
if you want a super chat i appreciate it
you want to support the show make sure
we also remember that we also have uh we
also have patreon which you trust me
content is coming for that uh more
content is coming for that but i have
some stuff up there already if you want
to take a look at that but if you want
to be a part of the patreon it's eric
griffin it's patreon.com eric griffin so
check me out there on on the tron on the
patron if you want to be if you want to
support the show further or you could
even be a subscriber at
twitch
if you wanted you know just if you just
want to support me and be like hey i
want to help you out you know i like
your content you're going to go be a
subscriber on twitch too and like i say
i do that daily you know i mean so i'm
on twitch eric griffin gaming so you
know hit me with the follow there all
the stuff is down below in the
description if you're interested in that
so yeah and all my major like
like the you know the workaholics boys
half of them are coming you know because
one of them has to work and the other
one's going to another wedding and it's
like that kind of stuff happens too you
know so like i really have no attachment
to it in terms of like if you can't come
you can't come you know that's just it's
like great just give me a good gift
that's been my thing you can't come just
bring me a good gift though but anyway
that's the wedding planning
uh so last week's episode i was talking
about uh you know the the purchase of
twitch got a lot of feedback on that man
so much feedback from people
you know with their own opinions about
like why elon bought twitch and not
twitch twitter why he bought twitter and
and like what it means and why he did it
and did he spend too much money or what
he's buying and everybody had their
opinions and it was great but i do want
to say i did get one response from
someone from something that i said so
you know as i was talking about
twitter and something that musk said
himself is that he wants to verify that
each person is a real person
so my thing with that i added to that by
saying like i think that yeah everybody
you should know who everyone is
and i was saying like you you should be
able to like go to their profile and see
their name that's who that is
you know as a way of like maybe
deterrent to trolling or maybe maybe
holding people accountable for what they
say but somebody hit me with some
pushback on this that i didn't even
consider
and it was actually a sex worker
you know uh somebody that you know works
in the sex field and she said well i
don't want my name
you know my twitter is
you know or whatever their social media
is is
their you know
fake name
and they wouldn't want their real name
there
and you know i never even considered
that um and there's probably other
reasons for people to be hidden not just
to be a troll or a coward
so you know i can understand that but
that being said i still think that the
company itself
maybe it's not public
it shouldn't be public but it should be
there though
so on your twitter profile the private
part of the
privacy part between you and the company
your name should be there so they still
should be able to know who you are so
some disparaging
things happen or maybe even
something happens to a sex worker that
we don't know you know
maybe the only way she could get away
from her assailant was like she tweeted
out help me you know what i mean the guy
took the phone you know and then we
could you know the twitter could be like
oh that's sarah such and such from
alabama and uh let's send the police
over there or something i don't know my
point is i'm just saying i still think
everyone should verify who they are
on their social media it doesn't
necessarily have to be public
but
people
i don't think anything should be
anonymous when it comes to
people putting out hate they put out
their
opinion if you're putting out your
opinion you're attacking people don't
attack people unless you can put your
name on it that's what i say
so
but i do like i said i took some thought
into that so if you have a good comment
or thing you want to send me you know
you know hit me up in the dms and stuff
like hey but just be thoughtful with
your thing give me a food for thought or
even in the comments because i will look
at the comments uh to check out you know
what people what what people are saying
out here in these streets
so you know there was
you know there was quite a bit of
comments um
[Music]
at the uh on this last episode episode
182 about elon the in the my nba preview
nba playoffs and then winning time the
show winning time so i did get quite a
few really good
comments um
you know so
if you like i say anytime you want to
have something to say just go in the
comments because i do look at them you
know people say don't look at the
comments but you know this is part of
the show so like i just i'm imploring
you to please like you don't have to be
a rude [ __ ] just you know
hey you like it's okay to disagree just
write it out like i disagree and by the
way too i think that it also would be
helpful is
if you disagree with something give your
take
you can't just be like oh you're you're
an idiot you don't know how business
works and then that's it
just be like i don't need that part
you can just explain it
since you know how business works
you know what i mean just explain why
business how business works
that we can you know we can move from
there it doesn't have to be this whole
like attacking me i don't know why
people love to attack but whatever it is
what it is
um all right let's get into one of the
things i wanted to get into uh this
episode which is this crazy
matte gala
you know i
what
what is that dude
so jared leto once again
like looking like a crazy person man i
don't know what
that is
what is that
like i don't even know
i don't know what to even say man
i didn't even know what it was so i
actually went to i didn't even know what
the met gala was
so i went to
you know
wikipedia
did you guys even know what the met gala
was so apparently
the met gala formerly called
the costume institute gala or the
costume institute benefit
is an annual fundraising gala held for
the to benefit of the metropolitan
museum
of arts
costume institute in new york
it's popularly regarded as the world's
most prestigious fashion event
and is highly sought after celebrities
from various fields such as fashion film
television music sports and social media
are generally invited to the gala
organized by the american fashion
magazine
vogue
i
never knew
any of that
you know
i didn't know
what
so
because up to this point
you know and then i i see that i i'll
end the poll now people say i said
without googling do you know what the
met gala is is about and so 67 of you
were like no and i totally get that i've
never
how would how would anyone know that
so here's like so jared leto like and
then if you guys remember
if you remember freaking
last year
this dude showed up
this dude showed up with a head
you know what i mean he had like a red
dress on and he showed up with a head
like what
like so i get but i guess
now that i have a better understanding
of
uh what this
is about
the fashion institute uh in conjunction
with vogue magazine because up to this
point you know
you kind of see it and then like there's
sort of like this weird
attitude towards it where people are
like oh it's just rich people showing
off and whatever but apparently this is
like you know
one of these things for the arts which i
think is important by the way i think
supporting the arts is important i think
that's important in society i think it's
important for schools i think it's
important for young people to be
involved in arts i mean yes there's
plenty of things you can like you know
there's plenty of things that you could
uh
have a have a foundation for or have a
fundraiser for or or donate or you know
what i mean um but charity causes you
know there's plenty of homeless and all
that kind of stuff you can do but i
think this kind of stuff is important
too so once you get bogged down into the
like the logistics of or the morality or
the good and bad of like
what you should be doing
you know charities for whatever you know
there's charities out there for whatever
if you you know just give money to
wherever you want but you know this is
one of these things that like i i just
but i still just
don't
get it man
i just don't get it
like if you look at some of like the the
people that were at the met gala so like
like who like look at some of these
these these outfits man
you know what i mean
if you look above me there there's like
who's that now that's uh that's what's
her face um billy eilish
it's like damn dude
you know of course lizzo she gotta be
crazy like i don't know is that a wand
that she has like what does she have on
man
i don't get this
oh and of course like you know rihanna
and like and what and what's her dude
got is he wearing a
is he wearing a quilt
is that a quilt
what is that
i i
wow look at them dude
like how do you how do you like
how do you decide this and like do these
people are they invited
or do they have to pay to go and that's
part of
the
what do you call it the um
the charity is that part of the
fundraiser that you invite all these
people to go and then they
um
i don't know
you know what i mean
oh thank you uh jessie for the 20
thanks for i appreciate that i
appreciate the super chat you know you
guys you want a super chat you'd be more
than happy i'd be more than you know
willing to accept your super chat
but anyways i don't know what that is
all right this one seems to be i love
this like this is like
what's his face um
what's that guy's name why am i
forgetting this guy's name
you know
[ __ ] whatever his name is
i'm terrible with names all of a sudden
like all of a sudden i don't know
anybody's name
ryan reynolds
you know like that's not now that's why
i go okay i get it
you know and even that outrageous outfit
this lady has on is like what the hell
is that but it's kind of cool you know
what i mean like that's pretty cool but
then you have some other people where
you just go like what
like like what is this
where would you wear this
i i don't i don't know like anytime i
see high fashion like anytime rachel
goes to a fashion show and she comes
back
and
she sells me pictures and i just go
who's wearing this
who's like who's wearing this stuff man
like i just don't get it man
i don't get it right
and you know it's like
what is the purpose
oh my god like look at this chick man
like like lizzo is just bananas dude oh
let's look at these matt gala photos
yeah this is better
i mean that looks nice
i mean is that hillary clinton hillary
clinton's there look wow
damn and then here's well if you're just
listening right now i guess that's
terrible for the people listening
[Laughter]
because they don't get to see the things
i'm looking at and there's pete davidson
with kim kardashian man i guess pete
davidson is living the dream huh
you know pete davidson man uh i mean
i guess i you know what's funny is i
remember
i remember like i was
i remember when pete was just like
just just starting out like doing comedy
i remember i was doing like the
new jersey comedy club
and pete was the opener you know he just
i just met him they hired him to be you
know and i was like hey man you know i
met him a few times and he's just cool
dude he was really like you know a
little introverted at the time and then
now he's like
a superstar like he's like i think he's
like an a-list celebrity man and i'm
here doing my little podcast i'm not
invited to the met gala
that's why i always say man when you're
coming up
when you're coming up it's good to try
to be good to people
no matter what level they're at like i
always say today's pas that's a
production assistant like on a set like
if you're on a set man
be nice to the production assistants
because today's production assistant is
tomorrow's executive producer
you know like um
so you gotta really like
you know be nice to people or at least
or at least be like respectful show some
respect you know you don't have to like
be fake but give them their due because
the next thing you know bam there you
are
you know so yeah some of these outfits
man it was crazy
uh
freaking russell westbrook i don't know
what he was wearing
like russell westbrook had on like a top
hat he looked like a crazy person but
that's this generation i mean you know
this is i mean i guess this is the good
of social media i mean this is like i
say if you believe this is a great cause
then uh you know here you are but
there's a lot a lot a lot of like
unconventional like crashing the gender
norms at these things now that seems to
be like the new thing
men wearing dresses and women
like putting mustaches on their face
like look at this chick she's got like
you know she's got a mustache on her
face
jesse buckley i don't even know who that
is
you guys know who some of these people
are like i don't even know who any of
these people are then there's like all
this fantastic jewelry that they have on
and all this like you know all this sort
of weirdness that's going on at the met
gala man so i don't know i just thought
it was kind of i thought it was kind of
weird
and when i saw this
when i saw this jared leto outfit
i just thought like it is
imagine him getting ready
like did he get ready at home
you know did he get ready
was it like a room and and the people
that made that for him brought him and
then he just walked out and presented
himself like imagine like like you're
you're talking to him over by the punch
and you're just like hey how you doing
like what do you say like that's the
conversation all night
it's like hey this wow hey jared uh
what the hell you know i got what do you
what do you even talk about they
wouldn't want me at something like this
because i would just be walking around
like
what
damn you got all fool yeah they would
kick they would kick me out
they would completely kick me out
yeah that's jared leto man like it's
just bananas right i guess it is i don't
know i mean everybody's putting up on
their instagram and that kind of stuff
and like making weird jokes about it so
i have no idea
i have no
i have no freaking idea man but the
whole thing is
the whole thing's bananas dude
uh but anyway guys let's talk about one
of the sponsors of the show helix sleep
um helix sleep
i love healing sleep i have a healing
sleep mattress and i'm just telling you
right now i think you should get one too
uh like anytime i go to the health place
they always talk about sleep they say
sleep is the most important thing so you
know exercising and being healthy is
important but another thing that's going
to help you is having the proper
mattress sleeping on a terrible mattress
is it can mess up your whole thing it
hurts your neck it hurts your back
healing sleep look they got a quiz you
take the two-minute sleep quiz you
complete it and it matches you to your
body type and sleep preference
and they send you the best mattress
that's perfect for you if you're big
boned you're a big person they got a
mattress for you you're a side sleeper
they got a mattress for you if you
combinations of these things they'll
figure out the mattress for you i'm a
side sleeper so you know it's got to be
a certain way for me and it is and i
love it completely um i took you know
like i said i took the quiz i'm a side
sleeper and he got it for me so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress and then
they match it to you and the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever have to go to the
mattress store again helix is awesome
but just don't take my word for it they
were the number one overall mattress
pick in 2020 by gq and wired magazine
just go to
helixleep.com griffin take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to the customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you but i'm
pretty sure you'll love it
helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helix sleep dot com
slash
griffin
boom
all right guys i uh i i so last week i
talked about that show winning time on
hbo max
i'm still watching it and i still feel
the same way i think all that nonsense
is distracting i think making it look
like the 70s is super distracting it's
like
the reason why
the reasons why things in the 70s look
like that is because the technology was
shitty
so they had to have it look like that we
got 4k and better cameras now i i
just have the show look like normal like
we're you know you know what i mean
so i don't like that i still don't like
that but because of that process um and
thank you jagged deep i can see you're
asking a lot of questions with your
super chats you know what i mean so
uh
oh apparently it's not jared leto well
well and whatever
everybody's saying it's jared leto so we
we're going with it basically my whole
thing is that matt gal is crazy but
anyways i watched um the uh what do you
call it the the mad you know the
the winning time and like i say i don't
like it and it's because of the things
we know about magic johnson but that led
me to
look at the magic johnson documentary
which is on apple tv
and i want to talk about that right now
the magic johnson documentary man
uh it's actually pretty it's pretty
interesting
and i feel like i almost feel like magic
johnson
saw or i don't know how quickly they put
this together maybe it was already in
the works
right
but you know after the jordan
documentary came out and it was fabulous
this ten part
you know thing about jordan and it
really like
you remember how great he was and you
know and it was obviously it was like
almost like a commercial for him and his
brand and like and he you know he
decided what everything that was going
to be in it and so yes it made him look
like a superhero that we thought he was
anyway but it was a pretty fascinating
documentary we got you know it and
people were talking about it after and
there was some people had trouble with
it some people were like oh boy that i
didn't like that you talked about this
like him and scottie pittman are
probably never going to talk again okay
after that after that documentary so you
know there's things like that man that
came from it but you had a better sense
of who who michael jordan is even if
even if he himself didn't want this
impression of him to be out there
you know you still had a sort of like
wow this guy's really arrogant you had
like a narcissistic thing about it and
that's probably not what he wanted but
it came across that way but he approved
it right so you you learn something so
anyway magic they call me magic it's on
apple tv
and
you know i was young like i knew magic
johnson later
in my life i was born in 72
so all this stuff was kind of going on
so i wasn't really a fan of basketball
and i actually didn't start really being
a fan of basketball until i was like
late like early teens
you know in high school
starting to think about playing
basketball because i was i started i had
a big growth spurt and i was like i
guess i could play basketball at my
small high school so that's when i
really started getting into basketball
and watching it and then michael jordan
like came on the scene and it was like
whoa you know i remember watching the
celtics i remember watching the nba
playoffs and i wasn't really a
basketball fan and it was that game that
jordan scored 63 points and i was
mesmerized i was looking at the tv like
god damn this dude can ball and it just
was like man like this guy's super human
and it was just was amazing to watch so
and then like i live in la and then
people are talking about the lakers and
so i would watch like i remember
watching the game
i remember watching the lakers celtics
when magic hit that little baby hook to
win the championship
and then i briefly like saw like when
like it was magic versus isaiah thomas
and i saw you know that and then it was
like then it just all became about
jordan after that and then of course
magic johnson you know the thing i
remember being in high school
and like
you know magic johnson has hiv and so
then
all you remember of magic johnson in the
last 20 years is that he has hiv and he
survived it and he's a businessman and
like it's all his post-basketball career
but this documentary really lets you
see the impact that he had on the
basketball community and how great he
was
and just like his personality like you
know he was michael jordan before
michael jordan you know in terms of his
like reach and um
presence and markability
so this documentary really delves into
it it shows his family life and it shows
his rise as this like high school
basketball phenom and how you know 9 000
people would come watch him play
basketball in high school as a 15 year
old and he was getting 30 points 20
rebounds 15 assists 10 steals he was
having games like that in high school
and then he was from michigan and then
he went to michigan state and then you
had like larry bird the great white hope
at the time when racism and
uh that race well racism was more
prevalent than but the the race
sort of like indirect race war that was
still going on where you know especially
in a sport and the nba wasn't very
popular in the in the um
70s and mid 70s it was really what magic
and bird
reinvigorated the nba and made it like a
thing along with you know
dr bus the late great doctor bus a
lakers owner
him making show time him saying hey
let's sell entertainment not just
basketball
and so magic johnson was at the
forefront of that he had this big smile
and he had this like you know big
personality and and he just was a
fantastic basketball player and he was
and then he like led the lakers to like
you know phenomenal magic went to nine
championships you hear what i'm saying
he went to nine championships and i
don't think he gets enough credit as
being the like just a winner and this
documentary is great it you know it
shows like
from his own like he gets to brag a
little bit you know he gets to talk
about
how he felt and like what he loved about
basketball and it was really interesting
to see him talk about larry bird
and how like they had this real
love-hate relationship you know it was
like it was fascinating to see him magic
talk about
when he first went to the championship
so they won the championship against the
sixers right
and then and that's when kareem got hurt
in the finals and magic you know he had
45 points and like it was one of the
greatest finals games ever to this day
and
the next time he got to the championship
he was playing against larry bird
and the celtics the lakers had never
beaten the celtics in the championship
and so he choked and i remember as i
started to like remember the feelings
that i felt i started to be like oh yeah
i remember this
it was like magic choked like i remember
that and he's talking about it and you
can see him in the documentary
how he's talking about it that he's
really feeling it still and he said even
right now as i talk about this i feel it
and it's like man to be that competitive
that you know you're long retired your
athletic career has been long over
people don't some people don't even know
you as a basketball player and he was
feeling it like it was just happening
and it was fascinating
um and then he talked about like you saw
in the documentary they had all these
pictures and footage of him from college
and high school and
how him and isaiah thomas were like
super close
it was it was they had this really close
friendship
and then when
the the lakers played the pistons in the
championship
magic like hard fouled isaiah and then
he said he says it on the documentary
and i was so glad that isaiah was also
on this documentary but magic said like
we were never friends again he was like
that ended our friendship
and it was like i don't know it was
it was like both
it was both tragic
and fantastic at the same time
in a sense that like
if you want to be an ultimate if you
want to win
if you want to achieve
there are so many sacrifices that you
have to make that maybe when you look at
it and you ask yourself is achieving the
ultimate thing
the like inherently good like is that
the most the best thing you could
possibly do and sometimes it's not
because it comes at the sacrifice of
your family and friendships and
so much stuff and then he's talking
about his wife to be cookie
cookie johnson and how and she's in the
documentary talking about like how they
he postponed the marriage and and he you
know and he was just you know being real
about like yeah he was like messing
around and you know having relationships
all over and i've only watched the first
two episodes as a four-parter and i'm
sure he's gonna get into like you know
the news about him having hiv and i
can't wait to see that and maybe i'll
talk about it next week when i finish
watching it but
you know man it just was so
fascinating
and then they did some good like uh
movie making techniques of like you know
they had time jumps so like the the the
the the
on screen it would go in reverse
and then you got the idea that oh he's
talking about now they're going
backwards and he would go back to high
school and say like hey this is what i
knew i wanted to do this and that and
like so if you have apple tv i do highly
recommend the magic johnson documentary
it was really good it's really good i'm
in the middle of it right now and it's
really good and it really just makes me
you know give give him that's probably
the point of it too because if you're
the star of a documentary you know it's
a narrative that you're trying to put
out there
and i think magic johnson wants to
remind people like yo i was great
you know like uh r.i.p to the late great
kobe bryant right
and i know there are people out there
and it's just because you're a younger
generation and you're like oh man
matt uh uh kobe bryant's the greatest
laker and i know magic said that but i
don't think magic really believed it
especially after watching this
documentary magic went to the
championship nine
times
okay nine times
um magic's the greatest laker ever man
he just is you know
and so many people were talking about
him and then it's like you know it's
like they're talking about the race
stuff and they're talking about like you
know it's it's pretty it's pretty
amazing
uh like i say it's a pretty amazing
documentary and i for sure give it like
[Music]
yeah so the magic joking documentary
gets like a bunch of woo-woos because i
think it's turtle totally
worth
the watch y'all totally worth the watch
okay
um
if anybody has any comments or questions
about it if you like you know
if you saw it yourself and you know you
have something to say you know you know
put it put it out there if you don't
think magic's the greatest uh laker ever
you know let me know let me know what
you think about that all right
um okay so now let's get into
a segment that i haven't done in a long
ass time and i really look forward to
doing it because i haven't done it in a
while and that is
real world advice
from a grown ass man
from a grown ass man
okay so
first up
and actually before i even get into that
i just i just oops hold on hold on hold
on get rid of these i'm doing this all
by myself
first i want to say this i'm just giving
you some common sense advice you know
from me
i'm a 50 year old man and giving you
some life advice that's all
um i'm not an expert i don't claim to be
uh if you have real problems out there
if you are struggling out there and you
have you're dealing with some depression
or some serious clinical things i really
do highly suggest you get some some
therapy therapy is really important it
really can be helpful it can really help
you organize your thoughts with a
professional that recognizes patterns
um and actually they're not even a
sponsor today but i say go to
betterhelp.com griffin
you know what i mean go to
betterhelp.com
griffin there it is right there and if
you want to get some help or go to
anywhere that you want to go you don't
have to go to mine you can go to
anywhere you want to go but i do suggest
you get that so some of these are just
fun light ones and some of them get sort
of heavy but you know i just give you my
thoughts and experience and that's all
that this is i don't claim to be an
expert um i'm just just giving you like
i say some real world advice um you know
that's all that that is all right all
right so first up and uh and this time i
i kept some of them anonymous because
people asked me choose i used to like
put that you can see their names and
this is from my instagram you know
people put their questions up on
instagram i put a question thing and so
these are the things that come up and
they're always in their private so
first up
what do you do when someone says they
want to be just friends
but you still have feelings
funny because i talked about this on
king and the sting today too on one of
the episodes of king and the sting i'm
not sure which one it was i think it was
patreon but i don't know but anyways
what i'm going to talk about here on
roofing with griffin
let me say it again what do you do when
someone says they want to be friends but
you still have feelings here's the thing
man
no one has to be in the friend zone
no one
if someone comes to you if you're if
you're
someone's in your life that you are
interested in
and you make your intentions known and
they say well hey i just want to be
friends your response can be
no
i don't want to be your friend
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with you putting out there
like hey yeah i'm not trying to be your
friend i have feelings for you
and now if that person's like well i
don't have feelings for you now you guys
can decide what you're gonna do next
you're either not gonna talk anymore or
you're gonna have some serious
boundaries that you need to set but you
don't have to hide your feelings you
don't have to pretend like you don't
have feelings and then also don't
pretend like you're being somebody's
friend like if you're not really if your
intention isn't to be that person's
friend
they should know that because maybe that
person is like oh this person's my
friend and they're being nice and this
is why they're sending me messages that
you know hey thinking about you and all
the stuff that you do when you're
recording someone you know what i mean
and it's like come on
let your intentions be known it's
totally fine it's totally okay to be
like hey
um this is what i would like and then
that person now can
now they
have to be in a position to be like all
right i have to like act accordingly too
so now you know then they can set
boundaries that they want and now they
know what what the energy is that you
are saying like if you like you know
what i mean like if you're hitting
somebody up at a certain time and it's
in a certain way they'll read that now
and know oh they're interested in me so
now let me respond accordingly it's like
you know what i mean and then at the
same time if if it's it makes you
uncomfortable if someone has told you
hey i want to be more and you just don't
want to be more now you could be like
all right and i'm sorry you can't be
like oh well i'm losing this friendship
that really means a lot to me that
person is only making you feel that way
anyway because they trying to get with
you
and you know what i mean so
communication is key
i think that is the most important thing
communicate your intentions
so you can be on the same page
so you know what your boundaries are all
right
that's what i say to that and good luck
all right let's go to the next one
oh that's not what we want sorry
let's get rid of that and boom
all right here we go
wanting to change careers i'm 28 and i
want to explore other paths and try out
different business ideas
i've had this question like so many
times actually i think about it um just
do it man
i've said this before i'll say it again
if you want to change careers don't let
the fear stop you but the thing you have
to do is plan it out
that's when because a lot of times we're
scared because
i'm changing careers but i have to pay
my rent i have to pay my house note i
have to pay my you know
uh you know i have my netflix
subscription i have this and that and
that and you so you when you think
you're to change careers you're starting
to think about your loss of income and
like and then also you might be insecure
you might be like oh can i do this it's
like you know that's why the planning is
important so it's like if you know all
right in a year i'm gonna change careers
so in the meantime i need to save money
i need to set myself up where i could
not work for six months or not make the
same kind of money while i'm chasing
this dream while i'm trying to achieve
this other thing have confidence in
yourself and your skills especially if
it's something that like you went to
school for or it's something that you
feel confident i could get this done
don't let life get in the way don't let
the choices that you've made to gather
belongings and things and places don't
let that stuff get in the way of you
achieving more down the line so set it
up plan it out because once you plan it
out and you have your goals set and you
and you set yourself up you're going to
feel confident that you could get it
done because i got this amount of money
in the bank i got this thing set up i've
made these contacts so it's like do that
stuff
while you're in the current career and
set yourself up for success
good
luck
wait got that one already okay that's
this one all right
okay let's go to the next one boom
all right here we go
i'm afraid to love trust again
they say shooters shoot but i can't seem
to pull the trigger or there's a lot of
subtext to this one and i feel like this
person is saying i'm afraid to love or
trust because their love and their trust
was broken by somebody
so
this just kind of similar to the last
one in a sense that this is all about
time and planning
one thing i will say to people is this
like if you've been hurt
don't close yourself off i know it's
easier said than done because this is
what ends up happening people close
themselves off to other relationships
for a while because they've been hurt
because their trust has been broken
because and then now they're sitting
here thinking well everybody's going to
do this to me and then they wait they
wait they wait and then one person comes
along that sorta makes you feel like oh
i can trust and love again but what ends
up happening then is it's a lot of
pressure on that relationship and when
that one doesn't work now you're like oh
no
what i'm saying to do is that was just
one person
you are not wrong for being vulnerable
you are not wrong for for opening
yourself up for for for allowing someone
in
that person was just immature and they
broke your trust
that person did not everyone is going to
do that so now moving forward you just
plan it out more now maybe now
you don't sleep with the next person
right away
maybe you go well i need to know more
about this person let's say like you
found out the person was broke and they
were lying to you for a while
making you think something else so maybe
now you want to be like i want to know
more about this person before i actually
you know dive full in
you know what i mean
we have to before we dive full in on
something you know what i'm saying
um
so that that's all it takes is just a
little bit more time now but what i'm
saying is don't shut yourself off
stay out there just have your guard up
you shouldn't stop dating to me it means
date more
find like go out casually with this
person with that person with this person
and just kind of get to know people like
even if it's superficial at first oh i
like this person's job oh i like what
that person does oh i like the
conversation with this person so you can
see oh i actually like a lot of
different things and then the person
that has a number of things that you
like might present themselves but you
you've allowed more people into your
life that you know you know that it's
possible that you know what i i'm going
to try with this person oh that person
hurt me but you'd be like you know what
that's just that's just the odds that's
one more person but now there's all
these other people so
stay out there keep yourself
keep
yourself growing and expanding keep
yourself
you know working on you being the best
version of yourself and that's not by
being closed off you know it's be by
actually being open
and just be cautious
um
but don't just close yourself off
because that's how you'll trust again by
having small trusts you know what i mean
uh you know it's like oh this person
said they'll be there at eight o'clock
uh they were um i went on two dates with
this person and they were dependable
like
add to your list of things like have a
bare minimum you should have a minimum
standard you know have a minimum
standard the person got to have a job
they got to have a place to stay they
gotta have a car maybe that's your
minimum standards maybe for your minimum
standards or even higher maybe
somebody's like ah they gotta be they
have to have a college degree they have
to have a career they have to have a
house whenever you make your minimum
standard make it and then look for it
you'll find a lot of it and then you'll
add more to it because you'll be like oh
they're really nice so they're really
good looking they're really good looking
and nice oh they're super funny uh you
know whatever your things are but ex get
out there expand don't just
don't don't just stay on your ass okay
i'm telling you
because there's people out there who are
gonna
surprise you all right
um okay
let us go to the next one and thank you
for the super chats janine we got to
have you as a grown man guest on
lifeline hey i'm ready let me know i'm
ready to go
uh and thank you jagdeep you're really
going in right now i really appreciate
you um great advice my wife's here and
loves what you're saying all right thank
you shout out to your wife all right
um
thank you both
all right next one
this is the next one um
how do i deal with being the funny guy
sometimes i wish people would ask how
i'm doing
man i can relate to this one
i'ma tell you a story with this one when
i was in high school i
i wasn't like i'd never played
basketball before so i started playing
basketball my sophomore year and then my
junior year on playing basketball and i
remember i was the funny guy you know
everybody's oh he's the funny guy and so
people would think they could say
whatever they want to you they don't
care about your feelings when you're the
funny guy people think that you're
always funny and you you know it's a
weird thing so i remember like i was
like
up and down with the with the basketball
i was i didn't know how to play i was
trying i wasn't my thing so like i was a
junior then i was on the jv team but
then like i got pulled up to the varsity
team and like it was like a rocky my
coach
rested r.i.p to him mr terry matthews he
recently died struggled with his health
for a long time but he was a solid man
he was the dean of students and the
basketball coach and he taught me
discipline he was a great great man but
he
but his people skills when it came to
like the basketball he would yell at you
man he would get in your face i remember
after a game crying he went off on us so
much we didn't play well cut to i
remember it was the basketball
awards ceremony the awards banquet
and
he said everybody he had a certificate
for everybody and then i remember he got
to me he forgot and he was like oh yes
and eric
uh oh eric you know and i was the clown
i was the fun guy and i remember him
saying like
he said like oh you know what i was
looking for somebody from the jv team to
put on the bench to sit on the varsity
bench you know because i was sitting on
the bench a lot right so he thought that
was a funny thing to say in front of
everybody's family and friends and that
eric the funny clown guy was fine that
hurt me
i remember that
i remember that really getting to me and
being like damn but
i went up there and i was like ah you
know what i mean i got up and i was like
yep that's me you know and i grabbed the
certificate and i remember i left the
certificate on the table
and that summer
i told my mom
i got to go to basketball camp
i said i got to go to basketball camp
and then i remember the new
mr matthews retired and this new coach
was going to be the coach and he said
some messed up stuff to me too like oh
he's like oh you trying out for the team
like who do you think is better me or
this other kid that was trying out and
he said that to me and it was after the
banquet and i was like nope
told my mom i need to go to camp
basketball camp and my mom's like okay
go to basketball camp so i found this
basketball camp and i went to it and it
was big man camp
and i learned a lot about basketball but
i came back
and i was ready
and i busted my ass my senior year and i
was all league that year and i got my
name at the time you can get your name
in the paper if you scored 20 points in
the game and i got my name in the paper
like three or four times
but
it was a kind of thing where i was like
oh man
i wish i had said something later like i
wish i had gone up to him not in that
moment but later and said hey man that
kind of hurt my feelings
um i
you know that that you said that in
front of all these people you
embarrassed me and i didn't like it
and i think that
that's how you have to deal with it
sometimes is you just have to let people
know
how you feel you know
i have to do that with rachel sometimes
like she likes to joke with me like she
was making a joke like when she's mad at
me she'll say like i don't know why i'm
marrying you you know but she'll say it
as a joke and she'll say it in a joking
way
and you know and she'll say it like we
were like last night she said like a
bunch of times so i said to her i said
hey babe
sometimes i need you to say why you also
want to marry me because i like to hear
that too
and she got it because she said oh i'm
sorry
you know she was like oh i'm sorry and
then we had to talk but it's like
important
like it's important so like if you're
the funny guy
i think it's important for you to
[Music]
you know let people know that there's
another side to you because we're also
can be annoying you know when you're the
funny guy you're sometimes annoying as
hell because you're always being funny
and you find you know and sometimes you
find situations where it's like maybe i
need to put some levity here and
sometimes that annoys people so you also
want to let them know hey i'm not just
that guy i'm also a guy that i feel i i
feel sadness i feel happiness i feel a
lot of different things and i just want
to let you know that so that's what i
suggest that you do
um
anybody that
gets pigeonholed into people to say that
you're a certain kind of personality
you know even if you're like
even if you're like somebody who's that
people say you're serious all the time
oh this person's i'm you know man you're
always serious don't you ever smile
sometimes you want to let them know like
hey yeah i do i have feelings too you
know what i mean ex you know just
communicate communication is the key
with this one so good luck and i hope
that that answered your question
all right
let's keep going i think i got two more
y'all
um all right here we go let's see
oh i get this one up all right that
one's gone
oh wait no i did that one already i
think there's only one more then yeah
there's only one more i think let's see
uh
yeah i'm [ __ ] you know doing this all
by myself so i get confused here we go
last one
i'm having difficulty moving on with the
end of a 20-year friendship any advice
i mean damn
i feel it
it sounds to me like you didn't want
this friendship to end but i don't know
all the details but this happens
sometimes people grow apart
things change we get other people in our
lives you know we get relationships in
our lives we get um
you know you get kids or you get a new
job or you have to move and these kinds
of things happen but if it is something
that you had a disagreement if it was a
disagreement and i'm just going to
assume that for a second that you you
had a thing that happened and you're
having difficulty with the end of the
friendship then don't let it end
my question to you is this and this is
for everybody listening to and anybody
in a situation like this
do you want to be right or do you want
your friend
you have to ask yourself that
and it is about being the bigger person
and it's not about being the bigger
person in the sense that you're looking
bad on that person it's just about doing
the right thing in the moment so you
could keep your friend
so it's like
look at yourself if you're in a
disagreement with someone and you feel
like you're right
really take a look at yourself and be
like all right well what can i do to
make this better could i see this other
person's point of view
make the effort that you need to make to
see if you can salvage your friendship
if you can't then have solace in the
fact that you gave it your best effort
and it didn't work out
remember the good times
cherish that
and you got to move on
you got to better yourself by getting
other people in your life and just
working on personal growth
personal growth is the best way
to
kind of like manage your feelings when
you're dealing with whatever you're
dealing with and that is like working
out improving your
time at
improving your job
putting better efforts into other things
in your life like hobbies and
relationships and because you're not
going to forget you're not going to
forget but you don't want to let it hold
you back
so you know it's about getting control
of those feelings and channeling them
into something more productive but i
hope that that works out and i really
wish you
the best okay i really wish you the best
y'all and that has been
y'all
real world advice
from a grown ass man
okay
there it is real well device from a
grown ass man look at me with the
graphics huh
huh with the graphics y'all
[Laughter]
i'm working it out
i told you i would
and i'm in i'm in talks with somebody to
like really come in and help me
on a regular basis
ladies and gentlemen that has been
another episode of your favorite podcast
riften with griffin um please as i say
subscribe
share
you know
do all that good stuff for me
uh
hit the notifications i'm on twitch
daily to check me out there
patreon content coming your way so if
you want there or if you just want to
support you can also just join patreon
just for that or you can sub on twitch
or you can become a youtube member
youtube members also get the exclusive
content so check me out there too
i appreciate you guys as always thank
you for the comments
um i i if you go to my instagram
if you go to my instagram story
i am answering a lot of the questions
that i get i do like you know videos and
i'm i have typed responses to a bunch of
the questions that are there so if you
want to see some of the responses there
i'm sorry that i can't get to
everybody's response but like i say i'm
not a freaking full-time therapist so it
is what it is i'm not a therapist at all
so but thank you very much for watching
we're from with griffin and i appreciate
you guys and have a wonderful week
see you next week
[Music]
thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]